first up we have kimberly arthur mensah
uh what is your question for chip and
joe yes first off i love love love you
guys thank you and my question is home
renovations big or small can be very
daunting what are some tips to stay
motivated and get things done i love
that i always say just start small it's
kind of like anything in life like you
can dream really big but to really start
getting things moving and make things a
reality you just got to kind of look at
the smallest thing tackle that then go
to the next thing and just start getting
your rhythm so for people that are
trying to tackle say a kitchen you know
it's like hey start with your
backsplasher start with new hardware
like you don't have to do the full
renovation and sometimes the greatest
joy is when you don't do the whole thing
and you just do a few tweaks and it
changes the space on a really great
budget so i always say start small and
work towards the bigger picture but
don't try to get it all done at once
great question thank you guys great
thank you
that's really really smart hardware can
change
everything right next we have you let
guys um what is your question for chip
and joe my question to you is you have
five beautiful children and i imagine a
couple of them are picky
so what do you do to get them to try new
things
that's kind of your thing sort of my cup
of tea joe is also picky so she
encourages
she encourages the children to think
very small and think very uh the same
things unadventurously
yeah and i'm always trying to teach them
that look new things are what teach us
new things you know how else you're
gonna learn if you don't try something
new so i'm constantly pushing that
envelope but i will say i've met my
match in the sense that some human
beings are so stubborn they refuse to
try new things no matter how hard you
try but i will say as a testament to
joanna stevens gaines if she can do it
anybody can do it amen we'll be here all
week ladies and gentlemen thank you
thank you thank you good to see you
thanks for that question
oh thank you nice to meet you
all right kimberly
what is your question for chip and joe
what is one design trend from the past
that you hope never returns
i feel like
a popcorn ceiling is an easy one i think
we already see that ever
unanimously
yeah shag carpet i think maybe that's
even debatable now well you've got some
really amazing shag rugs but i will say
i'm gonna i'm gonna rat joe out here for
a second if i might do it the first
project we ever did was this was this
great little house over just on the
other side of town and it had uh four or
five kind of like major areas to the
house joe had not found her
design aesthetic quite yet and joe
literally went through that project and
each room was like walking into an uh a
brand new different themed house joanna
said yes to a different theme in every
room in that first house didn't you i
sure did all right but then what happens
like how do you then find out what
actually is your cup of tea i was like
what room do i love the feeling of the
most and then our second house then that
became three out of the five rooms but i
was just experimenting as we were going
we were excited i'm still trying to
figure out what we were experimenting
and then next thing you know four kids
you know
here we are back to square one
thank you for the question for being
with us we're gonna be here all weekend
thank you ladies and gentlemen yeah
[Music]
you